[MUSIC PLAYING]
KRZYSZTOF OSTROWSKI: All
right, TensorFlow Federated--
what's exciting about TFF
is that it enables everyone
to experiment with computations
on decentralized data.
And decentralized
data is exciting,
because it's everywhere.
It's in intelligent
home devices,
in sensor networks, in
distributed medical databases.
And of course,
there's a ton of it
on personal devices
like cell phones.
And we love our cell phones.
We want them to be intelligent.
This data could help.
Traditionally, the way
we implement intelligence
is on the server.
So here we have a
model on the server.
The clients all talk to the
server to make predictions.
So all the data accumulates
on the server as well.
So the model, the data, it's
all in one place-- super easy.
The downside of this is
that all this back and forth
communication can
hurt user experience
due to network latency, lack of
connectivity, shortened battery
life.
And of course,
there's a ton of data
that would be really useful
in implementing intelligence
but that, for various reasons,
you may choose not to collect.
So what can we do?
Well, one idea is take all
the TensorFlow machinery
and put it on-device.
So here we have each
client independently
training its own model using
only its own local data.
No communication
necessarily-- great.
Well, maybe not so great--
actually, we realize
that, very often, there's
just not enough data on
each individual device
to learn a good model.
And unlike before,
even though there
might be millions
of clients, you
can't benefit from the data.
We can mitigate this by
pre-training the model
on the server on
some proxy data.
But just think of
a smart keyboard.
If, today, everyone
starts using a new word,
then a smart model trained
on yesterday's data
won't be able to pick it up.
So this technique
has limitations.
OK, so now what?
Do we just give up?
We have to choose between
more intelligence versus more
privacy?
Or can we have both?
Until a few years ago, we
didn't know the answer.
It turns out the
answer is yes, we can.
In fact, it's very simple.
It goes like this-- you start
with the model on the server.
You distribute it to
some of the clients.
Now each line trains
the model locally using
its own local data--
and that doesn't have to
mean training to convergence.
It could be just
training a little bit--
produces a new model,
locally trained,
and sends it to the server.
And in practice, we would
send updates and not models,
but that's an
implementation detail.
All right, so now server
gets locally trained models
from all the clients.
And now is the crazy part.
We just average them out--
so simple.
So OK, the average
model, trivially, it
reflects the training
from every client, right?
So it's good.
But how do we know it's a good
model, that this procedures is
doing something meaningful?
In fact, you would
think it's too simple.
There's just no way-- no
way-- this can possibly work.
And you would be correct.
It's not enough to do it once.
You have to earn it.
So we repeat the process.
The combined model
becomes the initial model
for the next round.
And so it goes in rounds.
In every round,
the combined model
gets a little bit better
thanks to the data
from all the clients.
And now hundreds or thousands,
many, many rounds later,
your smart keyboard begins to
show signs of intelligence.
So this is quite amazing.
It's mind-boggling that
something this incredibly
simple can actually
work in practice.
And yet it does.
And then it gets
even more crazy.
You can do things like
compress the update
from each client
down to one bit,
or add some random noise to
it to implement differential
privacy.
Many extensions are possible.
And it still works.
And you can apply it to
other things than learning.
For example, you can use
it to compute a statistic
over sensitive data.
So experimenting with
all the different things
you can do with
federated learning
is actually a lot of fun.
And TFF is here basically
just so that everyone
can have fun doing it.
It is open source.
It's inspired by our experiences
with federal learning
at Google, but now generalized
to non-learning use cases
as well.
We're doing it in the
open, in the public.
It's on GitHub.
We just recently started.
So now is actually a great
time to jump in and contribute,
because you can have
influence on the way this
goes from the early stages.
We want to create an
ecosystem, so TFF is all
about composability.
If you're building
a new extension,
you should be able to combine it
with all of the existing ones.
If you're interfacing a new
platform for deployment,
you should be able to deploy
all of the existing code to it.
So we've made a number
of design decisions
to really promote composability.
And speaking of
deployments, in order
to enable flexibility
in this regard,
TFF compiles all your code into
an abstract representation,
which, today, you can
run in a simulator,
but that, in the future,
could potentially
run on real devices--
no promises here.
In the first release, we only
provide a simulation runtime.
I mentioned that TFF was all
about having fun experimenting.
In our past work on
federated learning--
and that's before TFF was born--
we've discovered certain
things that consistently
get in the way of having fun.
And the worst offender was
really all the different types
of logic getting interleaved.
So it's model logic,
communication, checkpointing,
differential privacy.
All this stuff gets mixed up,
and it gets very confusing.
So in order to avoid this, to
preserve the joy of creation
for you, we've designed
programming abstractions
that will allow you to write
your federated learning
code at a similar level as
when you write pseudocode
or draw in a whiteboard.
You'll see an example of
this later in the talk.
And I hope that it
will work for you.
OK, so what's in the box?
You get two sets of interfaces.
The upper layer
allows you to create
a system that can perform
federated training
or evaluation using
your existing model.
And this sits on top of a
layer of lower-level modularity
abstractions that
allow you to express
and simulate custom
types of computations.
And this layered
architecture is designed
to enable a clean
separation of concerns
so that developers who
specialize in different areas,
whether that be
federated learning,
machine learning, compiler
theory, or systems integration,
can all independently
contribute without stepping
on each other's toes.
OK, federated learning, we've
talked about this as an idea.
Now let's look at the code.
We provide interfaces to
represent federated data sets
for simulations and a couple
of data sets for experiments.
If you have a Keras model,
you can wrap it like this with
a one-liner for use with TFF--
very easy.
And now we can use one
of the build functions
we provide to
construct various kinds
of federated computations.
And those are essentially
abstract representations
of systems that can perform
various federated tasks.
And I'll explain what
that means in a minute.
Training, for instance,
is represented
as a pair of computations,
one of them that constructs
the initial state of a
federated training system,
and the other one that
executes a single round
of federated averaging.
And those are still
kind of abstract.
But you can also invoke them
just like functions in Python.
And when you do,
they, by default,
execute in a local
simulation runtime.
So this is actually how you can
write little experiment loops.
You can do things like pick
a different set of clients
in each round and so on.
The state of the system includes
the model of the training.
So this is how you
can very easily
simulate federated
evaluation of your model.
All of this sits on
top of FC API, which
is basically a language for
constructing distributed
systems.
It is embedded in Python.
So you just write
Python code as usual.
It does introduce a couple
abstract, new concepts
that are worth explaining.
So maybe let's take
a deep dive and look.
All right, first concept--
imagine you have a
group of clients again.
Each of them has a
temperature sensor
that generates a reading,
some floating-point number.
I'm going to refer to the
collective of all these sensor
readings as a federated
value, a single value.
So you can think of a
federated value as a multi-set.
Now in TFF, values like this
are first-class citizens,
which means, among other
things, that they have types.
The types of those kinds of
values consist of the identity
of the group of devices
that are hosting the value--
we call that the placement--
and the local type, type of
the local data items that are
hosted by each
member of the group.
All right, now let's throw
the server into the mix.
There's a number on the server.
We can also give it
a federated type.
In this case, I'm
dropping the curly braces
to indicate that there's
actually just one number,
not many.
OK, now let's introduce
a distributed aggregation
protocol that runs among
these system participants.
So let's say it computes the
number on the server based
on all the numbers
on the client's.
Now in TFF, we can think
of that as a function
even though the inputs
and outputs of that
function reside in
different places--
the inputs on the clients
and the output on the server.
Indeed, we can give it a
functional-type signature
that looks like this.
So in TFF, you can think
of distributed systems,
or components of
distributed systems,
distributed protocols,
as functions, simply.
We also provide
a library of what
we call federated operators
that represent, abstractly,
very common types of building
blocks like, in this case,
computing an average
among client values
and putting their
result in the server.
Now with all this that
I've just described,
you can actually draw system
diagrams in code, so to speak.
It goes like this-- you
declare the federated type that
represents the inputs to
your distributed system.
Now you pass it as an argument
to a special function decorator
to indicate that, in a
system you're constructing,
this is going to be the input.
Now in the body of the
decorated function,
you invoke all the
different valid operators
to essentially populate your
data flow diagram like this.
It works conceptually in
very much the same way
as when you construct
non-eager TensorFlow graphs.
OK, now let's look at something
more complex and more exciting.
So again, we have
a group of clients.
They have temperature sensors.
Suppose you want to compute
what fraction of your clients
have temperatures
exceeding some threshold.
So in this system, in this
computation I'm constructing,
there are two inputs.
One is the temperature
readings in the clients.
The other output is the
threshold in the server.
And again, the inputs can
be in different places,
and that's OK.
All right, how do
I execute this?
First, we probably want to
just broadcast the thresholds
to all the clients.
So that's our first
federated operator in action.
Now that each client
has both the threshold
and its own local
temperature reading,
you can run a little
bit of TensorFlow
to compute 1 if it's over
the threshold, 0 otherwise.
OK, you can think of
this as basically a map
step in MapReduce.
And the result of that
is a federated float, yet
another one.
OK, now we have all
these ones and zeros.
Actually, the only
thing that remains to do
is to perform a
distributed aggregation
to compute the average
of those ones and zeros
and place the result
in the server.
OK, that's the third federated
operator in our system.
And that's it.
That's a complete example.
Now let's look at how this
example works in the code.
Again, you declare the
federated types of your inputs.
You pass them as inputs to the
other arguments to the function
decorator.
And now, in the body of
the decorated function,
you simply invoke all
the federated operators
you need in the proper sequence
so the broadcast, the map,
and the average are all there.
And that piece of
TensorFlow that
was a parameter to
the mapping operator
is expressed using ordinary
TensorFlow ops just as normal.
And this is the
complete example.
It's working code that you
can copy-paste into a code lab
and try it out.
OK, so this example
obviously has nothing
to do with federated learning.
However, in tutorials
on our website,
you can find examples of fully
implemented federated training
and federated evaluation
code that look, basically,
just like this.
They also [INAUDIBLE]
some variable renaming.
So they also fit on one screen.
So yeah, in TFF, you can express
your federated learning logic
very concisely in a way
that you can just look at it
and understand what it does.
And it's actually
really easy to modify.
Yeah, and I personally--
I feel it's liberating
to be able to express
my ideas at this level without
getting bogged down in all
the unnecessary detail.
And this empowers
me to try and create
an experiment with new things.
And I hope that you will
check it out, and try it,
and that you'll feel the same.
And that's all I have.
Everything you've
seen is on GitHub.
As I mentioned,
there are many ways
to contribute depending on
what your interests are.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]